The world is pretty big and incredibly diverse,
so whenever you’re somewhere and you think
‘it can’t get much hotter or wetter or
higher than this’; it probably can.
So where are the undisputed champions: Where
are the most extreme places on earth?
First let’s look at the world’s hottest
place.
Temperatures taken with a thermometer on weather
stations would have you believe that El Azizia
in Libya with it’s highest recorded temperature
of 58 °C or Death Valley in California with
it’s record high reading of 56.7 °C are
the hottest places on Earth.
But according to new satellite imagery data,
they’re not even serious contenders.
There is a salt desert in the east of Iran,
that’s about 480 kilometers long and 320
wide, called Dasht-e Lut, which, as of recently,
is officially the hottest place on Earth.
The surface of the sand here reaches a scorching
70.7 Celsius, that’s almost double the temperature
of your body.
So, I guess that begs the question; who is
the poor scientist who had to sit out here
with a thermometer and take a reading every
day?
I hope they had a fridge at least.
Well, we know scientists can be a little crazy
sometimes, but no one is that crazy.
The data actually comes from a NASA satellite
called AQUA that monitors, among other things,
the heat radiation of the earth’s surface.
From 2003 to 2010 the satellite would image
the entire planet every 1 to 2 days, giving
us data on temperatures, clouds, winds and
much more.
The local name for the desert is Gandom Beryan,
which means “Roasted Grain”.
The story is that travelling farmers spilt
their seeds on the sand and within just a
few days, it was scorched and ruined by the
heat before it could be collected.
Not that you get a lot of people travelling
through, it’s certainly no picnic out there.
But people do come to see the beautiful, otherworldly
sandcastles in the western corner of the desert.
The erosion has carved teetering towers that
make it seem like some lost, ancient city.
Right, so if that got you feeling a little
hot under the collar, let’s all cool off
by heading in the opposite direction; the
coldest place on earth.
The lowest recorded temperature is -89.2 °C,
taken in 1983 at the Sovient Vostok Station.
But the station was just there to make these
measurements, so, you know, the scientist
were being paid to be there, in cold hard
cash – very cold hard cash.
But imagine if your whole town CHOSE to live
like this.
Oymyakon is the coldest permanent settlement
on Earth, with some 500 people living in freezing
temperatures, up in the North-Eastern tip
of Russia.
In winter it has got as low as −67.7 °C
and typically averages -45 C (-49 F) in December
and January.
The craziest thing is that, unlike Antarctica
where you’re lucky if you get above -30
Celcius, even in summer, Oymyakon has hit
+ 34.6 °C in July, and normally averages
around 20 °C for the summer months.
Imagine trying to buy a yearly wardrobe that
covered a difference of 100 Celcius!
Enough about temperature, we’re moving on
to new heights, or just really high heights.
So what is the world’s highest point?
Now this seems like quite an obvious one,
right?
The highest point must be the highest mountain;
which is, yep, that’s right; Mount Everest
in the Himalayas.
But when we say “the highest mountain”,
what do we really mean?
We mean Everest’s peak is 8,848 m above
sea level, and no other mountain can match
that.
If you measure from the base to the peak,
which is quite hard to do because there isn’t
some nice red line that says “the mountain
starts here,” then actually the tallest
mountain is Mauna Kea, at a massive 10,203
m.
But it’s deep in the Pacific Ocean, the
first 6,000 metres of Mauna Kea are underwater,
so it doesn’t really help us find the world’s
highest point.
Let me introduce; Chimborazo.
Okay, I know it’s only 6,267 m above sea
level, but here’s the twist; its peak is
the furthest away from the center of the earth
of any mountain.
You know that globe you had in geography class
that was a perfect sphere?
Well the earth isn’t actually like that,
it bulges around the equator, so the land,
and the sea level, are actually a few kilometers
higher at these points than anywhere else.
Since Chimborazo is in Ecuador, named for
being right on the equator, it gets this little
boost from the Earth’s bulge, so its 6,384.4
km from the center of the Earth, which beats
Everest at 6,382.3 km from the Earth’s center.
In your face Everest, you midget.
So that’s the highest point, but what about
the lowest.
The lowest place on the earth’s surface
is The Dead Sea.
It’s not really a sea, it’s more a really
salty lake, 50 km long and 15 wide, and it
lies almost half a kilometer below sea level,
429 metres to be exact.
It gets its name from the almost total lack
of aquatic life there; you’re more likely
to find chips in it than fish.
Its salt quantity is so high that swimmers
just float on the surface, like a human inflatable.
But if we don’t stick to the earth’s surface,
we can find places much deeper.
In the Pacific Ocean, just south of Japan,
there is Mariana’s Trench and its lowest
point is called Challenger Deep and bottoms
out at 10,916 m below sea level.
Here the pressure reaches over 1,000 times
what it is at the surface.
So unless you happen to be an invertebrate
or other soft-bodied organism, you would probably
end up as soup under the immense pressure,
that deep underwater.
Have you ever had that feeling when you’re
at the top of a really high building or say,
a waterfall and you wonder what it would feel
like if you jumped?
Well you’re not alone.
It’s often called the “High-Place Phenomenon”
and some psychologists thinks it’s your
brain getting confused by the feeling of dizziness
and vertigo, even though no realistic threat
is being posed.
So imagine what it would feel like if you
took a trip to the top of Mount Thor, the
world’s greatest vertical drop.
This gigantic cliff face can be found on Baffin
Island in Canada and boasts a 1,250 m vertical
drop.
It would take the average person over 15 seconds
to reach the bottom if they jumped off it.
And because the world is a crazy place, people
do jump off it.
In fact, Baffin Island has become something
of a hotspot for Base Jumpers who brave the
Arctic conditions and Polar Bears to hop in
a wingsuit and scream “Geronimo” as they
take a wild plunge from Thor’s Peak
The thought of doing one of those jumps makes
my mouth go dry.
Do you know where else would do that?
The driest place on earth.
Down the west coast of South America, tucked
behind the Andes, lies a 1,000 km strip called
The Atacama Desert.
It’s so dry that it only receives around
15 mm of rain every year and as little as
1 mm in some parts.
That means if you spit on the ground, you’re
giving it more moisture than it’ll see all
year.
This isn’t just the recent recordings either;
geologists believe that it’s been like this
for some 200 million years, so, you never
know, an Argentinosaurus could have come along
and dribbled on the exact same dry spot.
Surprisingly, the land isn’t completely
barren and some plants and animals do exist,
mainly around the edges of the desert.
And some years, if you do enough rain dances
and manage to get over the usual 15 mm of
precipitation, then huge areas of the desert
burst into colour.
A variety of seeds and bulbs lay dormant through
the dry years but come alive in a visual symphony
when the rains do finally return.
When discussing dry places.
We should also mention The Dry Valleys in
Antarctica.
In an enormous continent of whiteness, these
are a strange sight; permanently ice free
valleys.
Well, they do have a very small number of
frozen lakes but it’s mainly just harsh
grey looking dirt.
The reason it’s so dry is due to katabatic
winds.
The surrounding mountains block the flowing
ice and then, when cold air comes over the
top, the gravity pulls it downwards, making
it rip through the valleys at up to 320 kilometers
per hour.
This heats the air and evaporates all the
ice and snow.
This wind also whips up tiny stones and sandblasts
the boulders into these beautiful carvings
called “vertifacts” that look like enormous
dinosaur skeletons.
It gives it the feeling of being in an alien
world.
And in fact, because of their alien-like features,
both the Dry Valleys and the Atacama Desert
are used to test various NASA projects, such
as the rovers for Mars and one of Jupiter’s
moons, Europa.
If you want to escape these dry sci-fi landscapes,
where better than the world’s wettest place?
Mawsynram, a village in north-eastern India,
holds’ the Guinness World Record as the
world’s wettest place with a current average
of 11,872 mm per year.
To give you some perspective, that’s ten
times what rainy old England normally averages.
The causes of all this rain are related to
the Khasi Hills, which are placed right in
the path of airflow that comes from the Bay
of Bengal.
One key factor is that the air coming over
the hills creates uplift and cooling which
increases the condensation, so it’s like
you’re constantly pumping the clouds full
of more water.
The title of “world’s wettest place”
is actually contested by two towns in Columbia;
Lloro and Puerto Lopez.
Lloro had an average of 13,299 mm of rainfall,
for a few years in the 1950s but the equipment
was pretty outdated so we don’t know how
much we can trust these figures.
As for Puerto Lopez, although it has decent
records to show a 12,892 mm precipitation
average, there are some months missing in
the middle of 50 years of data so unfortunately
they cannot claim the title.
Seems a bit harsh but hey, if you’re sitting
inside all day, you should have time to do
your filing properly, right?
If you’ve forgotten your umbrella, maybe
we should look for somewhere else for you
to go.
How about the world’s highest permanent
settlement?
This honour goes to La Rinconada, in the Peruvian
Andes.
It sits at the bottom of the “The Sleeping
Beauty” Glacier and is a whopping 5,100
m above sea level.
It has a pretty stable climate and is typically
a degree or two above freezing all year round.
So what’s the appeal for the 50,000 or so
inhabitants?
It’s one of mankind’s old loves; gold!
There are gold mines nearby and this is where
almost all the economy comes from.
But the way workers are paid is very strange.
Most are part of the cachorreo system.
This means they go 30 days unpaid and then
on the 31st day, they can take as much ore
as they can carry and hope that they find
gold in it.
It’s a complete lottery of course but it’s
common practice to pocket a promising looking
stone even when it’s not a cachorreo day.
As well as the peculiar payment system, the
city is not the safest place either.
There is no plumbing or sanitation system
and since mercury is used in the gold refinement
process, the water is pretty contaminated.
But hey, who needs toilets and non-toxic water
if you’ve got yourself some shiny shiny
gold.
And finally, if you really want to get away
from it all, you need to head down to the
most remote inhabited place on Earth.
Around 300 people live on the Island of Tristan
da Cunha, which is 2,000 kilometres from its
nearest neighbours on the island of St Helena;
that’s a long way to paddle if you need
to tell them to turn the music down.
The nearest continental land is South Africa,
some 2,400 kilometres away.
It’s actually a small cluster of islands;
one is uninhabitable, some are just wildlife
reserves, but the main island where people
live is 98km2.
And these people are members of the British
Commonwealth.
The island was discovered by the Portuguese
admiral Tristão da Cunha, in 1506 but was
only used as a stop off point for merchants
and whalers until the early 19th century.
The British declared it part of its empire
in 1816, due to two main concerns.
Firstly, during the war with the United States,
the US used it to launch attacks on British
merchant fleets.
And secondly, it was to stop Napoleon from
escaping from St Helena.
Napoleon had already escaped once before,
from a prison on Elba, near Italy, so after
the battle of Waterloo, the British took no
chances and sent him as far away as they could
from anyone.
The navy on Tristan Da Cunha would patrol
the waters and look out for any French attack.
Once Napoleon died, from arsenic poisoning
he got from his wallpaper, the fleet decided
to stay and so the island has been inhabited
ever since.
It was briefly evacuated in 1961 when the
island’s volcano, Queen Mary’s peak, erupted.
They have their own economy, largely from
renting out their outland fishing waters.
They also sell unique coins and postage stamps
that are something of a collector’s item.
Since it’s hard to trade when you live 2,000
kilometres away from everyone, most of their
supplies come eight to nine times a year from
South African fishing boats.
It makes ordering off Amazon a bit of slow
process.
They do have internet access now though, since
an internet café opened up in 2006.
But the internet is so slow on the island
that when someone wants to Skype a relative
the entire island has to turn off their internet
access to free up bandwidth.
The world certainly is full of extreme places
that push the limits and boggle the mind,
but unless you want to be incredibly hot,
perishingly cold, unnervingly high, incredibly
dehydrated, completely soaked, or just really
really far from anyone, then you’re best
of staying right where you are.